every one of their intellectual
opponents be it a conservative a
libertarian an old-school liberal
virtually anyone who doesn't bow to all
of their authority is somehow a bigot or
a racist or a homophobe or anything else
[Music]
my first guess is a political talk show
host and a former liberal who says free
speech is under attack by the regressive
left he says they're less tolerant than
any conservative he's ever met and he
also believes Democrats are bowing to
the most extreme elements of their party
and will destroy it would you please
welcome Dave Rubin host of the Rubin
report Davis an honor to have you here
I'm going to jump right into this and
and let's talk about what has happened
to the Democrat Party or the left or to
the progressive movement it seems like
they've they've truly gone off the deep
end well governor it's a pleasure to
talk to you and yes it doesn't bring me
any great pleasure to actually have to
talk about this you know I think you as
a conservative and most conservatives
want a decent left you you want to have
intellectual arguments with good
liberals and by the way there is a
history of good liberals in the country
that you may have differences of
opinions with but that fundamentally
believed that America is a good place
and that the Constitution is a wonderful
governing document of things like that
there are decent liberals over the years
classical liberals such as JFK or Daniel
Patrick Moynihan or I'm from New York
Mayor Ed Koch old-school liberals who
didn't want the government to absolutely
do everything but perhaps wanted a
little more government than say a
conservative or libertarian might what's
happened in the last say six or seven
years is that the progressive movement
which really is socialism just masked as
democratic socialism or whatever they're
calling it which by the way they're
gonna they're gonna ax the word
democratic by the next election cycle I
mean they're they're basically admitting
they're socialists at this point the the
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren wing of this
thing they've decided that not only is
the government the end-all authority on
virtually everything but that also and
this is the the real
sort of perverse part of this that every
one of their intellectual opponents be
it a conservative a libertarian an
old-school liberal virtually anyone who
doesn't bow to all of their authority is
somehow a bigot or a racist or a
homophobe or anything else and for me as
someone that was a lefty my whole life I
mean I I was part of this thing
my political awakening as I've as I've
talked about it and met more people in
the middle of the country and talked to
14,000 people at Liberty University I
mean I never would have thought I would
have ever spoke there years ago and met
just dozens and hundreds and thousands
actually because I was on tour last year
with Jordan Peterson thousands of people
all over the world who I have some
political disagreements with but are
happy to agree to disagree and want to
live in a pluralistic society and
unfortunately that's just not where the
left is right now so I will always build
bridges with people like you for
whatever our differences may be because
I know you'd be happy to discuss them
and so and I and that's the beauty of
what living in America is all about I
think you said it beautifully just then
David and Peary says what was the
turning point for you when was it that
you one day said these people have gone
off and left me it's a bridge too far
you know there were there were several
moments that I started thinking
something is wrong here I'll give you
one you know I've told these stories
many times I'll give you one interesting
one because I suspect that you know the
guy that I'm gonna be talking about but
years ago about five years ago I was on
air at the Young Turks and they're a far
less far-left progressive network that
was the network I was working for and
they were showing a clip of Fox News and
and you must know David Webb over there
right yes no David I do yeah so David
David is a good man he's a conservative
he happens to be black and I say happens
to be black because that that it doesn't
define him it's one of the
characteristics about him that he's a
conservative now and years ago I had a
show on Sirius XM radio and I was a
lefty at the time and David's a
conservative on the Patriot Channel and
we met in the hallway one day we struck
up a conversation and every other week
I'd go on his show we'd argue we'd you
know talk about issues so he became a
good friend of mine and then it's a few
years later I'm on air at the Young
Turks and they see David I think was
guest hosting for Sean Hannity
at night and they're playing clips of
him and they're talking about how he's
an Uncle Tom he's a sellout he's a
grifter he doesn't believe anything he's
saying how could he do this to black
people and suddenly it was so stark it
hit me in the most clear possible way
that these people who purport to be for
diversity and purport to be for
tolerance and the rest of it they see a
black man who doesn't think the way they
want him to think and suddenly they can
apply all of the worst labels that you
could possibly say about anybody to him
and I thought David's not the racist
here it's actually you guys because you
say you're for black people or you're
for women or you're for other minorities
but every time someone from those
communities speaks differently then you
want them to you hate them for it
another example of this would be you
know they say they're for women but
they're not for Sarah Huckabee Sanders
they're not for nikki Haley they say
they're for black people they're not for
Candace Owens or Thomas Sol or you know
any of the any Larry elder people like
that or they'll say they're for gay
people but they're certainly not for
someone like Peter Thiel who's a
supporter of Trump so this is the
bizarre reality that the left has
created they therefore groups and every
time you're for a group you actually
crush the individual and I'm for
individuals I believe that you can know
and control and live the best life for
yourself and and that that's a bottom-up
way of looking at the world and they
want to top-down look way of looking at
the world you really I think hit a nerve
when you were talking about the fact
that the left likes to look at people in
groups and I've often said as long as
the Left can peep keep people in their
group they can win because all I've got
to do is keep the groups grouped up
together conservatives we tend to see
people as individuals we don't see them
as black or white or our gay or
Presbyterian or Jewish we tend to see
them as individuals and I think that's a
fundamental difference it would that be
an assessment you would also agree to
well yeah well it's it's the fundamental
difference between say leftism and
conservatism but it also is the most
fundamental building block that you can
have not only for a country I mean we
have this in America this beautiful
document called the Constitution that
lays out our rights and then the Bill of
Rights which expands those rights but
the government did not give us our
rights right these are god-given rights
these rights the government can take
away your rights but it can't give them
to you but once you say the group is
above the individual you have to throw
out the individual who dare thinks
freely who dare takes another position
so a very simple way I could explain
this to you
is so on an on an issue like abortion
you know you see something right now
where the left which used to basically
say you know we're for abortion but you
can't have abortions 8 months in you
know they had some guardrails against it
now of course governor you as a
conservative now you're completely
against that and that's just fine but
the left used to have some semblance of
a mechanism to be able to fight its most
radical elements they no longer do so
everyone on stage right now at these
debates and Biden might be the slight
exception slight exception I'm not even
sure but these people they won't put an
endpoint on abortion I mean everyone in
their right mind of course knows that at
7 months this is this is a child this is
a living being so this is the problem
that once you start viewing people as as
the collective you're unable to
understand that they might have
differences with you because you've
defined them already and what I would
rather do and I think conservatives have
been very good at this in the last
couple years is say I don't care what
your sexuality is I don't care what your
gender is or your skin color or the rest
of it do you have good ideas and can we
work together to hopefully create a
society that's truly tolerant for as
many people as possible and that's why I
consistently find myself building
bridges in places that I didn't think
would have existed a couple years ago
speaking of bridges one bridge had may
have been broken down as the bridge in
Congress between Democrats and
Republicans over impeachment the
Democrats said they had an airtight case
it was rock-solid they had the president
dead - right they were convinced that
their case was absolute
to use a phrase unimpeachable it gets to
the Senate and they want to add to it
they wanted to bring witnesses in it's
like saying here's the soup it's perfect
but nobody will eat it so well let's
take it back in the kitchen and add some
more stuff assess for us what this
impeachment process has done to America
and whether it will help our hurt the
Democrats in this country
well it's deeply dangerous what happened
here with impeachment now I I was not
for impeachment from the beginning
there's no doubt that Ukraine is corrupt
there's no doubt that Trump had reason
to look into it and I'm sure all of your
viewers are well aware of that video
with Biden basically admitting what we
were doing over there so so putting that
aside the bigger danger here is that the
framers were deeply deeply worried about
what just happened what just happened
was the House on a purely partisan basis
decided to assault another branch of
government the legislative branch
decided to attack the executive branch
the branch of the presidency on a
partisan nature this is this is deeply
deeply dangerous because what it leads
to is the idea that no election will
truly ever matter that if you ever get
your the opposition voted in as the
executive as the president that if you
have a partisan legislative branch that
wants to take him or her out that they
will go ahead and do it so there it's
deeply dangerous and and to answer your
your subsequent question this idea that
this is gonna somehow help the Democrats
is completely crazy because if you ever
wanted to fire up all of the base all of
the Trump boaters if you wanted to make
sure because you know sometimes in a
reelection cycle they the base doesn't
come out again or maybe it just doesn't
have as much excitement as it did the
first time but if if you want to fire up
those people what do you do you you do
this crazy partisan impeachment now all
of those people come out and then
there's another piece of this that I
haven't heard people talking about on on
cable news which is I think that there
is a certain amount of people that are
somewhat apolitical but they don't like
the idea of all the government nonsense
and we're gonna destroy everybody on the
rest of it and they actually do want to
defend the office of the presidency
and I think those people now are gonna
break for Trump as well so I think the
Democrats are really gonna regret this
and not only that you know AOC
Alexandria Acacio Cortez who I disagree
with on virtually every policy issue she
actually made a decent point about a
week or two ago she said that basically
she and Joe Biden shouldn't be in the
same party and I think she's right you
the Socialists and whatever last
remaining old-school liberal there is
should not be in the same party anymore
and I think aided by impeachment I think
all of this could potentially lead to
the end of the Democratic Party and and
sort of a real split between the
Socialists and whatever is left of the
old-school Democrat Dave Bernie Sanders
is on the verge of maybe winning the
Iowa caucuses next week for the
Democrats could put him on a track to
get the nomination does that alone
potentially split the Democrat Party
that that might be it right there I mean
because there are a lot of Democrats
again people that you as a conservative
would not agree with on say taxes or
abortion or a litany of issues but that
are decent Americans that you know you
just have a protocol disagreement with
but I think there are a ton of people
that will say this is too much
Bernie talks about fundamentally
transforming America that is deeply
dangerous you know we live in the freest
society in the history of the world
where 340 million people have come from
all walks of life from every corner on
earth they've melted into the melting
pot right they've they've become part of
the rich American tapestry that we have
are we perfect no but there's no such
thing as perfection humans are flawed so
we can't have a political system that's
flawed but when Bernie says he wants to
fundamentally transform it
I view that as such a deeply dangerous
idea because we've done something so
great here what we should be trying to
do is expand freedom where we can on the
margins when we can do that but
fundamentally transform is deeply
dangerous and in a weird way I actually
think having Sanders go against Trump is
probably the best thing that could
happen for conservatives because then it
will fully be like the the idea of
socialism vers capitalism it'll be
collectivism versus individualism and
all sort of be out on the table and I
think America has such a rich history of
the individual that is so deeply
embedded at us in a way that it isn't in
Europe that I I think I think Sanders
will ultimately be crushed but it'll
it'll really depend on whether you know
the the people come out and support
Trump or not you know that second time
around which as I said earlier sometimes
there's just a little exhaustion there
well Dave Rubin thank you so much quite
frankly I think if we couldn't watch all
of this this year for free we'd all buy
tickets it would be worth it
delighted to have you thank you we
absolutely would and I look forward to
having you in here one day governor
thank you very much look forward to a
day thank you our thanks to Dave Rubin
host of the Rubin report which you can
find at Rubin report.com
also follow Dave on social media also
that's at Rubin Report